he knows we're carny are we recording
that record okay so uh Singapore intro
to dragon staff we focused on learning
how to do minimal Steve's but we kind of
learned started with more of the end and
work your way back so we started out
just learning how to roll the staff down
the neck spiral it up if you are rolling
from left to right arm which will
probably feel natural for most righties
right-handed people you want to take the
staff with your left hand hold it a
little bit left of center and place that
Center on the back of your neck maybe a
little left of your neck roll it down
the neck that looks like from behind so
I'm not necessarily perfectly on the
center I'm a little bit off center and
as I roll it down I can also give it a
push around so I'm both giving the
dragon staff some starting role but also
giving it a push around so it has both
roll and spin otherwise if I just roll
it straight down I'm just going to just
going to go straight down so we want to
roll down the neck and around so if you
get onto the shoulder on the arm
one of the things that we really talked
about there was making sure that you're
feeling how to keep it spinning
horizontally so as it rolls down the
neck you can really be in contact the
whole time sliding the hand down rolling
down the night giving you control
speeding it up and then as you give it a
spin this way don't just like collapse
your armor your shoulder and let it go
down there I'm going to fall off you
want to try to come out to a good
shoulder posture and arm posture you
want to you want to kind of come back to
making a circular shape with your arms
but we're doing that horizontally so we
roll down it comes to the shoulder maybe
you give it just a little bit of a
downhill for a moment but then you're
going to lift up into it so mostly you
can keep horizontal and then lift up to
get it past your head um once once it
starts rolling along the arm maybe it's
a little wonky maybe it's not quite
horizontal you can bring your other arm
underneath the arm behind the staff to
make contact with it a second point of
contact and that can help guide it to
transfer to the other arm whenever you
have two points of contact you have much
more control over how it's rolling and
how fast it's spinning and you can
correct how it's balanced whenever you
only have one point of contact you have
to rely more on balance it's really a
dance with gravity when you have one
point of contact you're applying force
and the other force that's being applied
is gravity so you're having to work with
just this one point of contact and what
gravity is doing to the staff to keep it
moving totally doable really awesome
feels great but having two points of
contact to arms touching the staff for
the neck and an arm
the staff gives you a lot more control
and ability to adjust tweak any mistakes
that might happen so I find it's a good
safe place to learn from two points of
contact and then work your way towards
one point of contact especially with a
big heavy dragon staff that doesn't want
to stop and it's coming at your head you
want to get that second point of contact
in there to protect your face okay so
yeah so we practice this transfer this
cross-transfer like so we even just
broke it down all the way to the elbow
so the center is kind of on this elbow
and you bring your other hand in
underneath and behind and then you're
going to lift up twist around so you're
getting used to with a twist how you can
cause spin by twisting the arms as
you're doing that because you're pushing
it it's also causing it to roll it rolls
up this arm and then switches over to
this arm in its rolling downhill now the
other hand is just really sort of
guiding it down so we really played with
that sometimes at first like when you're
trying to do that it starts going off
vertical which that's a whole other
thing you play with eventually but for
now really think about lifting it up
overhead and continuing to get to spin
horizontally so from there you know we
kind of got it started on the net came
around the hand transferred around here
that's almost a full minimal Steve but
notice how that was getting a little bit
too far ahead to go spinning around too
much was going to hit me in the head so
this brings up a good point um whenever
your staff is spinning too much and it's
going to hit you in the head or just do
something you didn't want to do all you
have to do is turn your body with it
this is something that's important to
really make this an instinct whenever
something's going on where the staff is
kind of feeling too fast start and
turning with it and then if you're
turning fast enough with it this app is
actually staying still as far as
even though it's going really fast so as
you're coming around cross maybe start
turning with it that gives you all this
time for to roll down your shoulder duck
out and keep going
what you may find is that during this
transfer neither of your arms are
balanced under the center and that's
okay when you have two points of contact
that gives you control however once you
make the transfer you want to try to get
that Center to go from off center and
roll back the point where it is balanced
on top of your arm coming towards the
shoulder as it's on the shoulder that's
when you want to ring the shoulder back
so you're aiming the center behind your
neck and that's where you can duck out
and you can really like you don't have
to spend a lot of time ducking out you
can really like duck down and bring your
head actively over to the other side if
you want I also find that during during
that duck out I tend to make a little
bit of a turn so when I'm turning what
the stats almost like it's just rolling
straight across the back of my neck and
shoulders and then I can stop that helps
smooth that tradition transition out so
finally we also play with more of this
like phage hostile flavor of minimal
Steve so instead of just rolling down to
the shoulder a negative duck you can
actually create great both a circle and
some lift so you're getting like a
spiral staircase a spiral of the arm you
take that and place it behind this ear
so that
your arm is a spiral staircase path down
to the back of your neck down to the
shoulder so it looks kind of like this
the trick there is once you put that
behind your ear you can't really see
what you're doing and you're just gonna
have to start to feel what's happening
in the dragon staff well that's
happening if you want to use training
wheels you can sort of pinch this making
a ring and helping to guide it just in
case it it's a little shaky but what
this what this sort of phage hostile
Steve does is it places it to the back
of the neck just like we started we
started the staff in this workshop
rolling down the back of the neck so
you're already starting to get familiar
with what that feels like you can also
just place it there by putting your arm
behind the ear and get right into that
down the neck portion of the role so
when you've got all those things put
together you have what it takes to do
continuous minimal Steve's over and over
again
and if they're getting a little out of
control use like that hypothetical use
two points of contact to keep the staff
and control keep it going head bounce
but so that's the basic idea of it um
see what else are we cover oh right
bonus points you can take this neck roll
and just keep repeating it so as it
rolls up the arm right as it's getting
past the elbow you're actually carrying
it over your head into the back of the
back of the neck again so this is a
great way to like drill this particular
thing over and over and it's also sort
of a fun little loop to throw into flow
or performance before you go on to
something else or maybe maybe you're
doing some other stuff and then you just
like ran to the back of the neck again
if you want and you drop your hat let's
see what else any other major stuff that
i missed feel like that's like the meat
of it oh just really quick fake Shah I'm
sorry uh she roll for those who are
denied she rolls the entry basically for
a forged key role look for whenever the
staff is rolling down the arm that would
feed into the Steve it's off center
right now but you actually want to roll
bring your arm in and get to the point
where the centers on that arm
so it's rolling down i bring it to
Center I've got my Mike Ross transfer
control go straight to the Steve exiting
the Steve as it's coming around here I
just take the free hand and put it
behind I'm right back into she roll so
it's coming around put that behind it's
both protecting my face from the way to
do and puts me right back into a chi
roll so you can just minimal Steve zero
and will Steve maybe the other minimal
steve g roll if you keep coming back to
that chi role is sort of like a rest
move or a crossroads move you can decide
to send it either direction or vertical
with it there's a bunch of stuff you can
do from there um yeah so I think that's
pretty much it enjoy the the backwards
here oh yeah
oh boy so with that it's you let's see
you could just go for it because it's
already rolling up your arm instead of
doing that little thing you can already
get it to coast over to your elbow and
then do a duck out that's quite fast so
here I am doing the reverse two year old
right I could just go for or the little
bit more long-winded version is to from
from a reverse Chi roll you kind of just
place it to the back of your neck and
that's it's this thing that we already
know now right so that's the less
frantic version is to just the place of
that Lynette go into your Steve there
you go um you like there are some other
ways things you can do there but there
always are endless or pretty large
extent anyway um yeah anything else good
good awesome all right enjoy keep
learning